يعود اليك نايف نايف اسود الاطلس في
مواجهه المتدور الاسباني اليوم البارحه
ضغط على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الحديث
عن ازمه التذاكر تذاكر المباراه حدثنا
اكثر عن استعدادات المباراه اليوم الحاسمه
سهام طبعا اكثر طلب ان يصلي وانا مالي
علاقه نهائيا في الاماكن العامه من
الجمهور المغرب بيسالوني عن التذاكر رغم
انه
اخذ منه فيفا طلع امس 5,000 تذكره مخصصه
للمنتخب او جمهور المنتخب المغربي عاده
سهام همم فيفا يحرس انه يكون المدرجات
ممتلئه بالجماهير فاذا كان هناك يعني
تذاكر مباعه ولكن اصحابه ما صدر همم بطاقه
هيئه وما ما يعني جزء تذاكر للوصول الى
قطر همم يقوم الفيفا باعاده الطرحه مجددا
للجماهير الراغبه بالامس خصصها للمنتخب او
الجمهور المغربي ولكن امس يعني كان في
موقف جميل جمع ما بين همم سعوديين ومغاربه
كانوا السعوديين اللي كنت تذاكر مباراه
المغرب
السعوديه طبعا بالصدفه كانوا شاهين
المباراه التذاكر المباراه هذه من من فتره
طويله بالصدفه صارت مباراه
للدوحه لدعم المنتخب المغربي لكن ده يعني
سهام انا اعيش من الوضع هنا موجود المغرب
لها دعم كبير جدا
الاطلس في هذه المباراه ضد اسبانيا خصوصا
بعد الاداء المتميز خلال المباريات
السابقه
سهام انه ما نحكم على اسبانيا في مباراه
قدام
اليابان او خسارتها من اليابان في
المباراه
في كلام كثير هنا انه اسباني يتعمد تخسر
من امام اليابان عشان ما تقابل للبوازير
في دور 16 هذه اعطيني مؤشر انه اسبانيا
بتظهر بشكل مختلف في دور 16 لكن في جانب
مهم بجانب معنوي اعتقد انه له تاثير كبير
جدا على لاعبين المنتخب المغربي همم في
همم موجود امهات كثير من اللاعبين همم
متواجدين في المونديال يدعمون اللاعبين في
التمارين يدعمون وما ايضا داخل المعسكر
ويدعمون في المدرجات بس سهام تخيل انت
يعني اي شخص طبيعي انه والدته موجوده في
المدرج وهو في ارض الملعب حيطلع كلمه عند
عشان يرضيها ويسعدها وهم دائما حتى
الامهات يتعمدوهم يحفزون لاعيبتهم
بالاسماء فتره التسخير فهذا يعني
دافع معنوي كبير
[موسيقى]
للاعبين المغاربه في بعد
امر ايجابي في هدوء كبير في معسكر المنتخب
المغربي في صفاء بين اللاعبين في تفاوض
توافق بين اللاعبين هذا سهام مؤشر تودائما
مهم ودائما يعكس لك يعكس على ادائه نتائج
المنتخب اذا المنتخب داخليا اذا اللاعبين
ملتمين على بعض مع المدرب دائما
والمغرب 2014